many of these migrants have been waiting
in tijuana mexico for years hoping to
seek asylum in the u.s
but along with thousands of others
they'll have to wait longer
a federal judge has extended an
immigration policy known as title 42
which blocks most of them from claiming
asylum
we've been waiting for so long for years
with title 42 in place we're not allowed
to request asylum god willing we can
find a solution because returning to our
countries isn't really an option
the policy introduced under donald
trump's administration allows the
government to expel migrants from the
u.s to prevent the spread of covet 19.
president joe biden was due to lift the
measure on monday but a coalition of 24
states sued and won
we understand title 42 exists due to
sanitary measures that's why we're here
today with proof of vaccination and our
cova tests we don't have the virus so i
don't think it's fair to apply this
order against us
more than 230 000 migrants crossed the
border between mexico and the u.s in
april alone without title 42 u.s
officials say the numbers could surge to
18 000 migrants a day
the city is at full capacity right now
the shelters are overcrowded and there
are many people who've been waiting for
a long time there's a significant
haitian population families and many
pregnant women with families there's a
lot of uncertainty and a lot of
frustration
it's a problem for biden whose approval
ratings are low republicans are also
focusing on the issue ahead of the
midterm elections in november
human rights groups say the crisis is
being politicized by both sides
the justice department says it will
appeal the decision in the meantime
thousands of migrants will be forced to
wait yet again
katya lopez
al jazeera